hi everyone if you're already here for
the structuring the day webinar from
khan academy kids thank you so much for
joining we're going to get started in
just a minute when folks have had time
to join thank you
hi
my name is sophie and i'm from the khan
academy kids team
thank you so much for joining today for
our parent webinar on structuring the
day and how some of the khan academy
kids resources and tools and support
center can help you
keep your days moving with your little
ones at home
i want to take this moment to say thank
you so much to our sponsors bank of
america
google.org
at t
and novartis for helping us provide this
support during school closures we are so
grateful
and i want to just acknowledge all of
you parents carers grandparents maybe
some teachers who have joined today
you're taking the time to figure out
ways that you can make your days maybe a
little bit more structured
maybe meet some more of your goals and
we're so grateful that you're turning to
khan academy and khan academy kids at
this time
i am sophie turnbull i'm from the khan
academy kids team and today i'm really
excited to be joined by two of my
friends and colleagues vicky lang and
dan too and they are both on the khan
academy team
today our big objective is to make sure
you know where to go to find tools to
help you structure your day and achieve
your goals during this school closure
period we've got a bunch of free
resources and we've got our expert vicki
joining to give us some tips and tricks
i think this will be really helpful for
parents who are thinking about ways that
they can help keep their children
learning throughout school closures
we won't cover in detail how to get set
up on khan academy kids how to download
the app and set up a profile for your
child
and we won't cover specific advice for
teachers that is all really important
stuff and if you go to the handout that
is linked in this webinar you'll see
that on the learning objectives page we
have linked to the getting started guide
and to the teacher guide and if that's
what you're looking for then i'd
encourage you to check those resources
out
what we will cover
is a quick overview of the khan academy
kids resources and then we'll spend most
of our time hearing about this idea of
structuring our day and we'll hear from
a pro on how to do this
and then we're going to turn it over to
you i want to spend at least 10 minutes
of today answering your questions and
hearing from you about what's on your
mind as you try and structure your day
with your little ones
khan academy kids is a part of khan
academy but it's a separate app it's a
mobile app and it was designed
particularly for children ages two
through seven just like khan academy
it's completely free there are no ads
there are no subscriptions in the app it
is a really rich and educational and
also entertaining experience for your
two to seven year old
it has a range of activities we built it
with head start so it has a lot of the
academic and non-academic activities
that are really useful for getting your
preschooler kindergarten first grader
ready to go on and succeed at school so
it includes math and reading also things
like telling the time and life skills
like getting dressed it has a huge
social emotional learning aspect to it
things like understanding emotions and
expressing frustration which i think is
really important during this time
and it also encourages children to get
up and move around to draw a picture for
a friend and get creative it is so much
more than just drilling the hard
academics and that's what we hear from
parents and and that's what they really
love
during this time of school closures we
have had uh think about and we've talked
to parents about what they're finding
useful and one piece of feedback has
been the app is amazing but i'm just
really struggling to structure my day
how much time should we spend on khan
academy kids versus play time or doing
other things that are so important
throughout day and and how on earth do i
get any work done in this
mind-bogglingly confusing time and one
thing that we have come up with at khan
academy is a set of schedules that just
gives you a recommendation a guide a
starting point that educators and
parents alike came together and helped
to form that says maybe you could
structure your day like this so on this
page in your handout you'll see a
template for the daily schedules they're
the khan academy schedules and they go
right from preschool right through to
the end of high school so if you've got
a child of any age and you're listening
to this webinar they'll be helpful for
you we've also included this more
guidance link and that is the khan
academy kids team has added some very
visual and fun schedules specifically
for
children ages two through seven and if
you're looking for something where you
can actually engage and build a schedule
with your child then i'd encourage you
to have a look at those extra examples
from khan academy kids
and we put these schedules out
having heard that they were important
but we could not have prepared ourselves
for the feedback that we got from
parents you know
one of my favorite quotes is a parent
who says i just got teary-eyed reading
the khan academy schedules you know
these are fantastic parents just saying
that it has really helped them to get
some degree of normalcy back into their
day
and so i really want as many of you all
to access these schedules we'll be
sharing the handout and you'll be able
to click on those links and check them
out
but what i thought would be really
important was to acknowledge that they
won't just work as is for everyone and i
wanted to invite my friend at khan
academy who is an incredible parent and
educator and child development
specialist i'll let vicky tell her story
but i'd love for vicki to share with you
some tips about how you can really use
these schedules as one tool that might
help you structure your day and some
other important things that you can keep
in mind as you're doing that so i'll
hand over to vikki
yeah thanks sophie um what a wonderful
introduction and what oh just a wealth
of fantastic resources
you all have put together at con kids i
just my my six-year-old loves it it's so
fun
um
so yeah i'm gonna talk to you a little
bit about the specific schedules that
we've put together at con kids um and
uh and sort of the bigger principles
like what are some things to think about
as you're structuring the day for a
young child um especially if you are
also trying to get work done at the same
time because we are all i'm living that
myself right now all trying to do 1700
things at once um
before i launch into that just a little
bit about who's talking to you um i'm
the learning scientist at khan academy
um i did i help all of the teams
understand how learning works and how to
design for it
i've been doing learning design for a
long time um first as an elementary
school teacher and then an ed tech and i
am the parent myself i'm a single parent
of a six-year-old so i have a lot of
practice she's in kindergarten a lot of
practice doing two things at once
and i'm living this currently of her
kindergarten being closed
and trying to figure out how to how to
structure this day for her while also
continuing to try to do my
my job um
so let's look at what some of these key
principles are
of
what we're trying to do when we're
structuring the day for a kid and why
you would want to put structure on it
at all if we can go to the next slide
can we go then slide
thanks
oh sometimes it freezes up i know that
feeling that's a terrible feeling
um
so what we're trying to do the real goal
of trying to think through structure
is to create a space where kids feel
safe and secure so that they can learn
and you can work
safety and security are good um
especially in an uncertain time like
where how we are right now and then it's
also true that kids who feel safe and
secure learn better their brains are
more ready to learn and they're also
better able to play independently when
it's time to play independently so that
you can get your work done so it's kind
of a win-win all around
um
and that's going to help
you to be able to get even just a few
hours of work done or not if you're not
working either way it's still good for
the kid to know what to expect
throughout the day and then hopefully by
the end of the day we can all go to bed
still liking each other and getting
along
reasonably well by the end of the day um
even in this stressful time
so the big ideas to keep in mind because
as sophie said
every family is different and what works
for one family isn't going to work for
another so so i want you to be able to
modify the tools that we're providing to
work for your specific situation and as
you do that i want you to know what are
the big ideas that i want to keep in
mind
going forward
as i make changes um so first clarity
and communication is really helpful for
kids when kids know what to expect and
what's expected of them that helps them
feel confident it helps them
feel like they are empowered to act
independently and they can trust that
it's going to work out
because they know what's expected of
them when they know what to expect they
come to trust the world as a safe and
reliable place um that they can walk
around and it's gonna be okay in general
um so having that clarity of a list of
this is what's gonna happen throughout
the day and we're going to stick to this
and if it changes i'm going to talk with
you about that and partner with you
about that
so that the kiddo is just aware of
what's going on for them
that really helps them to feel secure
connection is also really important
connection with any trusted adult is an
important part of uh security for kids
they constantly need that connection cup
refilled
this is when you start to see um
attention attention seeking behaviors
and it can be really helpful um to
reframe them as connection seeking
behaviors that kid is wondering like are
you not just in the physically present
in the room but are you really able to
attend to them really see them and hear
what they need and be available for them
um even just for a brief moment and
connection can be really hard us really
hard especially when we are managing so
many different things and also trying to
work and our kids don't understand why
we're home but not able to be with them
all the time
um and so connection is something that's
like lost and re-established many times
a day in any family
and sometimes it's taking a break to go
be with them on part of their schedule
and we'll talk about that and sometimes
it's just as we do a lot of staring
contests at my house just a quick minute
let's reestablish eye contact i really
see you i'm really here with you i'm
going to give you like a a not a half
hug while i look at my laptop but a turn
to you like a real hug just for a second
before i go back to work um
that can really help that kid feel more
secure and then choice um is another big
idea
um that helps kids
develop a sense of self positive self
control and autonomy it gives them
practice with planning it helps them
understand that they can make a plan and
they can carry it out and they can feel
successful with that if we give them
just a manageable number of options and
set them up for success
um
so that's going to support their
development and their executive
functioning skill as they grow and it
creates ownership which means the kiddo
is more bought in and more engaged and
more motivated to do what they need to
do during the day because they had a
little bit of choice in when they're
gonna do it and exactly what they're
gonna do
so those are the big ideas
that i recommend trying to build into a
schedule that said
everybody is in
just chaos right now and so you're doing
great whatever you're doing is great um
these are just some things to try to
carry forward
so let's look at um
and this sorry if you can go back for
just a second this picture on the right
this is my daughter
and you can see choice there um this is
our schedule that she's standing on and
then she's got activity carts there and
she's
thinking about where she wants to put
her cards during the day and so this is
something that we do every morning at
breakfast but
you're going to be able to figure out
what works for you and your family
looking at the next slide what might
actually go in your schedule
you know it depends on how much time you
have and what your school has provided
with you and it's
for you and it's going to vary depending
on what you're able to do
but if you look at a typical early
childhood classroom or a preschool
classroom these are the topics they'd be
trying to cover
um reading and writing that should say
writing some math we have both of those
in con kids it's fantastic um social
time with other kids even if it's on
video with a play date or or with adults
free play time where they can be
creative and get some large motor
practice and small motor practice
and science and social studies are you
going to be able to do all those every
day
no i'm not able to do all those every
day like there's a reason teaching and
parenting are two different jobs and we
don't have people ordinarily that are
full-time parents and full-time teachers
um you're not going to be able to do
that and give yourself some grace and
patience um
but we're all doing the best that we can
and if you can go to the next slide
we'll look just briefly at um the
examples of some of the things this is a
sneak preview of what's coming for you
on friday um
with through con kids so there's a
couple different structures one of this
is the written one um there's an option
on the left where you can write in
the times that work for you activities
there's activity cards and there's a
space where you can write in the name of
the grown up or you could just write
independent if it's independent time
that might be with that kiddo because
then the kiddo knows it's easier for
them to play by themselves for a half
hour if they know when you're coming
back
um and then there's an option on the
right if you don't have the time or
space to invest in in that that level of
connection then there's a version that's
just for your kiddo to fill in their
activities and you can pre-fill it if
you want to be consistent every day and
limit the number of choices whatever
works for you
um if you look at the next slide i think
there's some examples
here of how that might look
um
we do things like
read on video chat with grandpa um while
i get an hour of work done every day
that's something that's helpful um
or you can just fill in
free kind of pre-filled activities and
then on the next slide this is our my
last example um is
the visual schedule for younger kids who
can't read yet don't understand time yet
um we've provided these pictures where
you can kind of build there's a blank
template or there's a pre-filled
schedule
and you can fill in what's going to work
for you and you can even young kids can
have choice and where they put
different things to whatever extent
you're comfortable with
and with that i will turn it back over
to dan who's going to say just a little
bit more about
where to find these resources and then
we'll take questions
hi thank you vicky and thank you sophie
um i just wanted to cover off a few
things before we get to resources and
open it up to live questions um first
attached to this webinar we have a
handout section so please grab and
download the version of this
presentation it contains a complete
walkthrough of what vicky and sophie
walked you through in terms of how to
structure your schedule why it's
important
and what content to incorporate into
your um into your schedules it also has
links to resources like live activities
including circle time which we recently
spun up on our um khan academy kids
youtube channel as well as printable so
if you want to do things offline these
are really important activities that the
team
is working on creating for you as well
and then um as always you know we have a
list of other resources available for
you both at can both on khan academy as
well as khan academy dot org slash kids
that's where our main khan academy kids
pages live and if you have any questions
feel free to email con kids at khan
academy.org if you have any any
questions
and the second thing we'd ask you to do
is if you have any questions please add
them to the question box um i'll be
facilitating while uh vicky and sophie
do the hard work of actually answering
the questions
all right so we already have quite a few
questions really good questions coming
in um i'll start off vicky this one's
probably for you from senthil
this is a funny one are we sure we can
have a timetable for a two-year-old
that's where the picture one comes in
that's a great question so kids kids
that young you're right don't understand
time it's too abstract but they can't
understand sequence so we're having
snack now that means next we're going to
read a book
and next we're going to do nap so having
just the order of things can help kids
to understand what's first next last
thank you and then we have a question
from carrie actually i can chime in a
little bit before i pass it off to
either of you so carrie asks you know
i'd like to know any tricks on how to
get a six-year-old to enjoy reading
either by someone else or by himself as
he learns to read i read with my nieces
and nephews as they were growing up
throughout all the ages and the way i've
done it that's worked for me is we'll
take turns reading like a little
paragraph or a sentence and often acting
out the character or just like
enunciating and just playing along with
it just beyond the page has been really
helpful for me and so sophia or vicki if
either of you'd like to and you know
provide your own tips there
yeah i think reading with a variety of
adults it can be exciting my daughter's
much more excited to read to her
grandmother than she is to read to me
um
another thing that that uh can help is
uh sometimes as parents we're really
excited for them to try to learn and we
try or try to read and we can push them
a little bit i know i tend to fall into
that sometimes and um if we back up and
just let them go at their own pace give
them room to make mistakes give them
wait time while they're sounding
something out just let them take their
space and slow down that can make it
feel like a lower pressure activity for
them and they can be more excited to
engage in it
and the little bit that i would add is
that the khan academy kids app has a
whole library of thousands of books a
lot of them are our own original
characters so there's five really happy
animal characters and some of them are
about nature
and you should really check those out
too
perfect
um and then sophie this one's probably
best for you gold asks is there a way to
access khan academy kids through a
browser um i have two kids but only one
mobile device for them to use
yeah the short answer is no the khan
academy kids app was built for really
little fingers so it's designed to be on
a mobile device that can be manipulated
and so um it works on a chrome touch
screen but not on the typical desktop
browser experience that's something we
would love to build and i'm really glad
you've asked that question
i guess in that scenario i would say
maybe having one child look take a look
at circle time which is available in
browser because it's hosted on youtube
and that's a 15 minute or so reading and
interactive activity that's supposed to
really represent that circle time that
kiddos have in preschools and schools
all over the country and then maybe
using some of our printables
if you have a printer at home we've also
adapted them if you don't have a printer
at home there are some offline
activities that maybe your child could
get excited about and thanks so much for
the for laying out that scenario that
you've got i'd definitely love to take
it onto desktop someday
yeah i would just echo what sophie just
said it's the team's developing a
tremendous amount of resources that are
off the app as well sophie's uh one of
the stars of circle time so you get to
see sophie repeatedly visit there as
well
and then the printables are just
adorable so i think that's a really fun
activity that you can take offline as
well
we have a great question from jason and
i can start with this and then probably
pass it over to you vicky so jason asks
how do we navigate between this schedule
and what our districts are sending us
i would just echo that we created this
these schedules early on before any
other public schedules were really made
available and so we were developing it
to fill a void that we saw that was a
need um and if you know and obviously we
don't want to conflict with what your
districts are advising for you um so i
just kind of give that background before
i hand it over to vicki
yeah yeah that's a great point and
i would just say that
uh different schools are doing different
things and you you can fill in if you're
if you're working within one of those
blank templates where your child has
some choices
you can just fill in the fixed things
right just write in nine o'clock circle
time with class before you even give
them the sheet um we do that here i fill
in like where i have a work meeting and
i'm not gonna be available to be with
her so she knows she can't schedule math
or something during that time
um so then you're just limiting the
number of choices that they have based
on what free time they actually have to
schedule um you can also put other
constraints on it like we need to do
exercise in the morning because
otherwise you are off the walls by the
afternoon or math has to happen in the
morning because your brain is tired at
the end of the day um
so just pre-filling i think is what i'd
say
okay perfect um this next question
sophie perhaps you can answer this
question so
ernesto is asking is khan academy kids
target targeted more towards native
english speakers
a khan academy kid is an app in english
we have actually had a lot of great
feedback from english language learners
who are using the app an example might
be the the read aloud feature in the
books is a really helpful way to onboard
to then reading independently
and there's lots of very simple guidance
and reinforcement delivered by the
narrator cody bear throughout so i would
say
it is in english and the learning will
happen in english but i think it can be
well suited to english language learners
as well
and anessa we'd love to hear feedback
from you um you know
if you have it on what that is like for
you and your experience but we've had
good luck with that so far
thank you for that sophie um so this
question is super important because i
think many of us are facing this uh lori
asks any tips for a very small living
environment where a child doesn't have a
dedicated school area so we talked about
scheduling with time it's interesting in
terms of scheduling with space
yeah
that's that's a great question because
we didn't talk about that at all but it
is great for kids to have a space that's
a consistent workspace just as it's
great for us as adults to have a desk
that's organized where we get our work
done because your brain kind of switches
modes um if you don't have that i think
you can still signal
um
work work time and work brain um with
just a special folder or a special area
like a corner of the room where there's
a pillow to sit on and a clipboard or
anything that is kind of dedicated for
the use of learning specifically and not
used for other purposes i think can can
serve the same function as having a
dedicated space
perfect um i have a question from kater
here and probably sophie you could
answer this one does khan academy also
provide suggestions on physical activity
physical
you know we have a physical development
section so if you can kind of dive into
that that would be terrific thanks
sophie
yeah i think a really big part of the
khan academy kids app is that we
recommend that it's used for 15 or 20
minute session at a time and we we
really don't see
kids getting stuck in it because we
bring them out of the activities to do
something physical so an example might
be
we get them to act like zoo animals and
that's always a really fun time where
they go from manipulating something or
reading something to you to actually
getting up and moving around
i think so that's like the app actually
prompting physical activity i think
throughout the app there's just a great
emphasis on getting outdoors on moving
around on and having adventures
and so treating khan academy kids is
like a good a good role model for that
and that and using it in a really
balanced way um is one way that we see
kids being really physical we just we
saw these amazing tweets uh this week of
kids dancing around and they created
forts and they were talking to the
characters and you know there is just so
so much theatrics that goes on with
early learning and i think the app
really encourages that
awesome so kind of related to this one
um it's asked quite frequently right now
so i'll just kind of ask on behalf of
everyone else and actually i can chime
in here as well um there are many
questions about how to regulate or think
about screen time especially in a time
like this
so sophie or vicky do you want to
volunteer and i can chime in
sophie do you want to start and i have a
couple ideas
yeah happy to start so
the number one principle for the khan
academy kids creators who are parents
themselves has always been that you know
parents really know best and parents are
best parents and carer is the best place
to come up with a balanced very
nutritional media diet some like to call
it for their children
we really defer a lot to the guidelines
of the experts
people who the world health organization
and the american association of
pediatrics on screen time and that's why
we recommend that 20 minutes a day mark
for our two to seven year old learners
it obviously can be flexed up for the
older ages and and really that's what we
tend to see is working for families as
khan academy kids becomes just one part
of a very balanced day that to vikki's
point has a lot of free play has a lot
of outdoor time ideally and a lot of
movement
yeah and i think that there are
different ways of using screen time i
think that there's
more and less educational ways in this
day and age there's also more and less
social ways it may be the only way that
your child can get social time with
other kids their age which is an
important part of a kid's development
so that's something to think about as
you're figuring out what feels right for
your family
one of my favorite tips
as you're trying to limit screen time
coming from having been a single parent
raising a toddler is podcasts
um podcasts serve almost the same sort
of like
uh kid entertaining function while you
need to do the dishes that a screen
sometimes can
without the screen so there are some
fantastic education podcasts around
science there are some for the really
little ones there's some really good
storytelling podcasts
out there
and if you have one of those home
speakers that listens to your voice the
child can actually play it for
themselves it's just like robot play
stories podcast and it will do that um
and that is uh
has been very helpful and supportive for
me as i try to do more than one thing at
the same time and still want her brain
to be growing
yeah and i and i think youtube hit the
main points i would just echo i think
part of the reason why the khan academy
kids team does such a um is so
thoughtful about creating these
additional resources whether it's circle
time physical activities within the app
as well as the printables is really to
provide a mix of activities for you all
and then to vicky's point about
screen time being a social activity i
think you know with this the shelter at
home mandates many of us are using
screen time as a way to communicate with
with our families remotely so just think
about screen time also like not all
screen times created equal and to also
create a balance of a mix of activities
for you to use
okay
with that um i think we're almost out of
time so i think that's that's all we
have for questions um i'd like to close
out with a couple of things first sophie
and vicky thank you for sharing your
expertise today um and then i wanted to
thank our fabulous audience for taking
the time out of your evening to be with
us we know you're extremely busy and we
appreciate you investing your time with
us in this session um if you missed
something or if you want to go back and
review for those of you who registered
for this webinar you'll automatically be
emailed a copy a recording of this video
and for those of you who may not or
you know of other people who would be
interested in watching with what what
you just saw and get access to those
resources well this recording will be
posted and made of be made available
online
and additionally we have quite a few
resources on khan academy.org as well as
khan academy.org kids
specifically for younger learners and
we're updating those resources daily so
um be mindful that you can come visit
those pages and you'll see the updated
versions um pretty much every day
and then before we sign off we do want
to ask you to do us one more favor and
take the poll that pops up at the very
end of this webinar and we want to know
two things from you first how can we
make this future iteration of this
session even better for other parents
and then secondly what kind of session
would you like to see next from us in
fact this session was actually a product
of feedback we heard from you all our
first section was a very high level
overview and many of you asked for more
structure and more tips and that's what
this was meant to do and so we're
continuing to listen to you and we're
here to support you so please provide us
with that feedback
and in closing we all of us recognize
that you're juggling a lot as parents
here you know this is really uncharted
territory for all of us and we here at
khan academy just want to remind you to
be kind to yourselves um it's okay you
know we're all in this together and
you've got this
so with that from all of us at khan
academy thanks again and good night
you